hey
everyone hey hey
hello
hey yay we have
we have felix we have v we have oola
we have the whole crew here
first three interviews actually from the
no limit society
the brave ones right
all the crazy ones the first to go into
the fire
yeah yep
and we've been able to play around with
awakening and enlightenment together in
our
rounds of tennis and you can find those
conversations in the playlist that's
linked in the bio below we highly
recommend checking those out
now we set up this first ama together
this ask me anything and
we've already got over the last couple
of days some
crowdsourced questions and
we'll go ahead and start with the
question that is
listed below we have a few more that
will pull up
and if you guys would like to throughout
go ahead and submit your questions
in the live chat and then
after we get through these first three
we will pull your questions
in and answer them so
all right let's go ahead and have you
three
start us off whoever feels most
excited in their highest excitement the
question is for those
on audio only it is is there more than
one type of awakening
and the follow-up sentence to it says i
no longer
fear death and am aware of much
but definitely never experienced samadhi
and samadhi for those that don't know is
a meditative
state of consciousness a very unity
oneness
state of consciousness
so is there more than one type of
awakening
so i can take it um
i would say there there can be different
depth of awakening
so basically the the general idea of
awakening
is um you could say reality
becoming aware of itself
so then the thing is that
uh the very nature of reality we could
say is awareness
so it's very nature it's being aware of
itself
so already the the whole concept of
awakening
is a kind of a fraud but
that's the the whole point of of the
play
the leela of everything that appears
so then in this context
[Music]
there are different degrees of
distortion
of the one knowing itself
and so awakening is kind of tracing
back those distortions back to the
source
which is this awareness this
this radiance this knowing aware of
itself
and um yeah so there are different
layers we could talk about different
layers of
the self and all the the illusory self
and um and so basically awakening is
a process of
more subtle layers of oneself
becoming more uh apparent more activated
more
radiant more shiny
oh yeah i would say
yeah go go ahead felix do you want to
wrap that sentence quick
yeah i would just think and like
it seems that different um yeah
different degrees
but in the end it's all the same
movement
there's one direction but then you can
start at different points and you can
end up at different points
here somewhere
that's nice yeah yeah can i add up
something
as well yes please yeah for me it's this
um
the whole awakening journey is kind of
going from the i am this little person
this allah
being right to wow on the
whole of existence and prior to the
existence right
um and and is because we are such a
unique
makeups we are such a unique human
beings
with such different unique conditioning
and levels
and of understanding this undoing
of that little all ourselves it has got
very different flavor to everyone right
which we spoke atlas on our
call as well which is the awakening
has got very different flavors to each
to each of one
because we are such a unique beings and
and
we have to undo this our unique
expressions and conditionings
uh so and it has got different levels to
it it
is almost kind of like never-ending
journey
into deeper and deeper into yourself
until you fell out of the black hole
right so it kind of goes spinning around
and around and around around until you
got sucked in
and through that little veil and then
you are beyond the reality you are prior
to
to this material reality the world as we
call it
and yeah so i think um
uh is there more than one type of
awakening is
it's the one awakening to the same truth
for everyone however every single one
has got a different flavor to it every
single one of us
that's my um view and understanding on
that
beautiful how many
ways are there to realize
that you are not who you think you are
there are as many ways to realize you
are not you
as they are used in the universe
there is only one awakening but there
are
currently eight point
sorry 7.8
billion ways of being misled into
believing
you are something else
i will quote or show here
who am i
is the only revolutionary
act in the universe
asking that question and
finding out
one of you you are i
maybe we could also address the second
part
there is not a question but
feels a bit more personal and
uh yeah that is it's touching mother
called the
the the question for this question
yeah cool
it seems to me like um just the phrasing
like
definitely never experienced somebody
it seems to me that there is quite a
strong
expectation or picture
of what it should look like and then
comparing one state with that
imagination and and
and thus imagining oneself to not be
there
well the the whole point of samadhi is
realizing that
you're it and you can never not be it
what to talk about what is
again ah yes
exactly and also i would like to put
this i am aware of much
who is aware of much right
to look at the one that is aware of much
who is
aware of much can you look at that one
who is looking who's aware
right who's that
exactly the me the big misconception
about samadhi
is that to visualize it are
kind of fireworks uh as a
extraordinary
out of the ordinary state
while it is simply the state
you are in when you are not there
and it's very ordinary again in
the words of osho it is extraordinary
which is just more ordinary than
all the [ __ ] you are used to
yeah that's beautiful we expect some
fireworks like you said exactly we
expect that this is some
incredible you know ecstatic experience
is going to
happen but actually it's so beautifully
simple
right is this oh this is what i am
without this fight yeah the fireworks
and the ecstatic
uh experience the spiritual profound
experiences kind of that there are still
experiences right
within that uh i am
so but the i am itself is just more not
most natural simple beautiful
thing there is a fireworks actually
it's you you are the fireworks
when you are not there and
you want to see the fireworks while you
are the fireworks
actually there is a moment where it
happens
it's when you are
fully conscious of being that fireworks
it's as if you could see it
and in a way
being it is like a dance
at first you think that the best way to
appreciate a dance is to watch a
beautiful dance by a very graceful
dancer
but that only until you realize that
there is a more beautiful way
to watch a dance it is to dance it
that is somebody and you are it
don't look for it you are it you're it
this is the beautiful tag game
be like children
and then even the looking for it
becomes part of the firework becomes
part of your play yes
and proximity to children
and being childlike being childlike is
the most mature way of being
if you are adult being childlike when
your child
is being in unrealized somebody
being like when you are an adult is
being
in realized somebody but the entire
idea of this dance is to go from
unrealized to realize that it's all the
same
and in the middle is where is the most
difficult part
because of the darkness the perceived
darkness
but the perceived darkness the darkest
perceived darkness is when you
are actually exploding into the firework
you are seeking
is extremely
close to childlikeness
and surrounded with beautiful children
and she's about to explode in fact
it's a it's one of those incredible
fireworks
with multiple explosions
i'm already exploding vinton
that's why multiple explosions some of
them already having
happened some yet to happen it's a it's
a
one of those beautiful long rich
fireworks in dubai you know where they
last forever and they
feel the entire sky on multiple
kilometers
yeah it's it really is explosion
uh yeah for what i meant when i said
when you're in i am
that the i.m.ness uh for me doesn't feel
like firework exploding but the
expression
in form is all for me exploding
fireworks right
so prior to the form is the simple
beautiful
stillness and silence that has got no
um it's prior to
fireworks exploding yeah that's the kind
of space i'm talking about and then from
that everything unfolds it's like the
firewall just suddenly jumps out and all
of the creation happens
and it is super ecstatic and firework
like i thought i'd agree
and being a child like if like being
this
person like uh you were saying felix
yesterday is
being like careless right carefree sorry
carefree being this um huge difference
just go yeah huge difference totally um
being this you know just go out and play
without having concern you know how do i
look like how do i sound like you know
am i good boy am i bad girl you know all
of this nonsense that we have in our
mind sometimes it is being
self-conscious
and self-aware of you know how am i
acting how am i presenting myself
children don't have that right to just
go out being themselves fully themselves
expressing their aliveness expressing
their nature
right it's beauty of freedom
and that's the childlike nature which i
think
we all look at children it's like oh my
god being a child again why
i'd love to feel like this again but hey
we all have it available
into for us for us like at any time if
you want to reach there if you wanna
exp if you wanna embody that it is
present in our adult life
and that stay that playfulness that
um freedom
i know anybody who knows what he's doing
when preparing a fireworks
will not schedule the firing up
in the middle of the day you need
emptiness and darkness in the sky
to fully appreciate the beauty and the
expansion
and the light and the colors of the
fireworks
and this is the purpose of what you
call the dark knight of the soul
it is the setting up of the background
of the substratum
for the magnificence of
your flowering
into realized nothingness
yeah to realize everything comes out of
nothing right
everything
and all the while is nothing that's the
most funny part is
it feels to me like the the exploding
point of the firework is
is the crystallized identity
this which feels like me
coming in contact with the true eye
that then burst it open and there is the
the light and there is the
the show the true
eye being the third eye that people
talk about but they visualize it as
another
set another retina while
it's actually another entire
complex of skin eardrum retina
all factive sense and uh
dopamine sense and all of it yes
it's a it's the third eye spelled
i not spelled in any other way and
especially not e y e y
there's a clue there there's a clue why
there is a y
in the middle of i that's a clue
that's a good one why is there a y
in the middle of it
there were many great ones by you guys
there
i really appreciated those answers
so much beautiful depth so
briefly would like to take the audience
on a journey
in understanding the general
navigable roadmap of awakening
just reflect on all coming from the same
source
and you reflect on that process and
then you see that in this process of
emerging from the same source
that the first
most salient attribute
is the very fact of awareness
just sort of sit as your eyeballs your
eyeballs are the size of ping-pong balls
and so if you just kind of sit
and reflect on as your ping-pong balls
looking and just become really aware of
that
process and then
the so we went from source to becoming
really aware of our awareness
and then we look at hey look
it's a pen it's a water cup yay
pens and water cups right so most of
society right now
is looking at pens and water cups right
so they're looking
at objects and so now awakening is the
process of seeing okay
source awareness objects
and so you just move away from objects
to becoming hyper aware of awareness
and it's both gradual and sudden
so in a sense this what's been described
as these pops
so you pop from looking at objects to
pop
to being aware of that which
looks at the object so the actual
awareness itself
and then you become aware that oh
awareness is source the source of all
reality is my nature i
am the source that makes awareness and
that makes realities
in the divine play and so
you could say that the more than one
type of awakening
is popping yourself from the
the object to becoming aware
of awareness and then becoming aware
that awareness is in fact
impersonal it's shared
and that's what's known as this one god
self the all-inclusive awareness the
great i
am that is eternally witnessing the
infinite creation
and then there's another pop to the
actual source the very
nothingness that's been described that
we
arise from and go back to and so
that would be the quote navigable road
map and then
the state of samadhi is just
resting in the
awakened state of that recognition
and so that's how i would
respond to that question do you guys
have any thoughts on
what i just said or should we move on to
the next question
i just want to briefly say that i saw
the moment of someone awakening
beautifully and away
he described that he was like oh i just
realized that i
all around this matter don't exist
there's only seeing left
right so rather than focusing on i all
are you just you just
become that's it you just you just keep
focusing put your attention on the scene
the fact that there's
the operation of seeing right and then
you become that thing so you become that
eye of god right
you see as god sees uh and everything
then becomes a kind of
uh you know experiential
wonder of like a watching a movie uh or
something that is fascinating
so yeah i love i love that so always
just seeing left and then
just notice and pay attention to that
saying just
just that seeing which is i just call
awareness
beautiful so
good to go to the next question you guys
all right cool
so let's hide our question about is
there more than one type of awakening
excellent question and let's bring up
our next question
which is are there different types
of intuition
oh that'll be if some if every single
one of us
says what is intuition for you for them
for you
then we will save the different types
right
so do you want to go eddie
hmm okay so
um
so let's take this picture of um
we have a sphere of awareness
there is there is some some aspect of
reality that we are aware of
and the rest of it is also
us but is is veiled for now
so from this standpoint it's like um
intuition then is the the penetration
of a bubble of awareness by
some kind of of knowledge of
um of knowing of
some kind of nudge of intelligence
of love of wisdom that is guiding
our current sphere of consciousness
into um into
more realization and more actualization
or expression
of that purity from which
this impulse is coming
so it's like this process of um
of the unconscious becoming conscious
and so then i would say can express in
many different ways
because then we have like this whole
mental body
that can be activated in many different
ways
[Music]
with the different senses and with
several
perceptions and feelings that can all be
used
as a little cues
to guide us on the right track
maybe one last thing that i could add to
that is that
these subtle cues can come also from
different
layers um
more or less close to the source more or
less
pure and vibrant and intense
so yeah i think that's a good start
thank you yeah i like someone called
this kind of gps right i sometimes call
it satna
uh it is it is our inner guidance
this is i think for intuition for me is
the way that hi itself
speaks to me through me and then what he
wants to express into this world right
i like that the universe is universe so
it's
one big orchestra one big song however
we all different tunes right
so we we all each receive like a
different instrument we all receive
unique
tone unique um song that sings through
our heart
and we receive through that tune through
that song through that
intuition or some color we receive the
knowing the information
of is the knowing is that that's what
we're receiving from the higher self
of this is where i need to go now this
is
what i need to do now this is what
um what rings true for me
right now in this moment right this is
well my next step
this is what i need to say so
is this knowing inside of ourselves that
the guides us
to navigate through this thing called
life right
and to express in these very unique ways
so each
one each event it comes from the same
space again
it is coming from the same universal
uh knowingness right however
it speaks uniquely to us with the unique
song which wants to be sung
through us um so i think that's
how intuition how that sounds
how that is for me so that's why being
true to yourself being authentic and
true and
in tune with your intuition is so
powerful because then you are
you are one with that um
you know you could say your life purpose
but it's just it's just the way
life unfolding i would say your own
unique
of what you came to express here
yeah absolutely
i explained it best through
my beloved also
who
alerted his followers
and humanity on the different
components and expression of
intelligence
intelligence beginning within
it all comes from inside inwards
and it cannot
be otherwise there are different
densities
of intelligence
instinct
is your essentially your karma
it's your hard-wired
practical material defensive negative
intelligence
intellect
is your mind is your language
is your ability to define
who you are not and to understand
and
strategize and construct strategies
to maintain your state of separation
from all that is it's artificial
and tiring but it's also
useful and beautiful and necessary
for the choreography of these bands of
life
and finally comes intuition
the education that your higher self
provides to your lower selves
the tuition inside
that intuition does not use language
no gestures even though it will refer
to your about your memory data bank
of emotions experiences language
to to try to connect
uh that data bank of memory and your
experience to a higher truth
but your higher self
is constantly showering on you
and indeed your focus
or rather de-focus your de-focus
on the lower forms of intelligence will
allow you
to benefit from
the access to the higher density of
intelligence from your higher self
it is a way of
widening your the spectrum of your
consciousness
to your higher self
and each and every one of you 7.8
billion
ways to express the same
feeling and
proximity to truth
beautiful i think it's also important to
say that it speaks in so many different
languages and ways right
because you say it doesn't speak the
words and language and things i actually
find that it speaks
so many ways like you can come through a
dream
which you know kind of the meaning of it
or you can come from the visions
or i even sometimes hear the voice in my
head that tells me something right tells
me like this is going to happen kind of
uh gives me that warning and um
and also you know even you know looking
at the bed sometimes it's fixed to you
or or hearing the song with certain
words like just exactly what you needed
to hear at the time
it is it speaks so many different ways
like it's almost like the whole
existence speaks to you right
only you can have to tune in to be able
to receive
but that information so
again the more awareness the more you
you reside in that space of
awareness and you be able to see more
and more subtle
things and messages and information and
you're able to tune in more
to hear that song if you are very
careful
it will it will remind you
of what you didn't know but you knew
um and if you watch carefully you will
see that these multiple
many languages are all known to you
because in reality you cannot perceive
from the small
self point of view anything that has not
been
stored consciously or unconsciously in
your memory
however as you expand and as you detach
from your smaller self you ground you
you are granted and you gain
access to a wider and
vast
space intelligence of
universal memory and
finally to
yeah is this again is this coming out of
this little mind of things that knows
right forgetting that
and actually stepping into the the space
i know nothing
and then you're a very receptive you
really receptive you become like a
student
so so you're receiving you're under the
thinking
space but he also is from that vessel
mind body spirit conflicts right because
you are
always ever creating that for yourself
you brought up one of the most important
point that when
was not mentioned that absolute
necessity
of extreme courage
and lucidity to recognize that you know
not that you know nothing that whatever
you think you know
is flowed that in reality in truth
you know nothing that is the starting
point
the it's the prerequisite it's the
permission slip
for real knowing
to reveal itself
to the you not there anymore
you you
you need to
to remove yourself to
turn yourself inside out to
realize that your idea of you is fair
and that
that you who you think knows
anything does not know anything because
it is not
but that is a very difficult thing to
understand
with the mind but it it is obvious
when you open yourself to intuition
and it is any expression of it which
will sound so sophisticated and complex
and and inaccessible while the reality
of it is extremely interesting
your natural building ability
to be not the you
that you think you want to be just to be
to be what you really are which is all
that
yeah because you are a little person i'm
the owner knowing this and that or i
am the vessel for the intelligence to to
work through
through me and speak to me and through
me right so i'm either
ola who knows i am the whole
intelligence speaking through me
like being the vessel for that
intelligence is one of these just the
most beautiful
experience we can have as a as a human
beings right
alive and having a life and living a
life
i find that um allowing
this flow through me is just like
mind blowing it's just com it's
uncomparable to being a little
human being you know this little mind
and completely
fixated and looked at and stuck
somewhere
i think it was sadhu that that is
beautiful the iev is really powerful for
me
it said optimist believe
positively pessimists believe negatively
they're both
afraid to admit that they don't know
right yes and i find this is just i love
it it's just one of my favorite things
it's like yeah just doesn't matter what
you believe
is belief right if uh
and then drop that you don't know you
become the student
and the magic happens the first
admission which is the prerequisite is
to
say outline say out loud
without restriction without
any holding back it might not be the
actual truth
that you know nothing
then that makes it possible to realize
that the
you who knows nothing is not you
the real you knows everything but the
you you think you are knows nothing
that's for sure
but if you begin from by the wrong end
by saying
the real me knows everything
the problem is because you have not
already a clear understanding
of who is that real me that you
believe you are it's extremely
counterproductive
that is why i revealed to bentino
directly not through this gated
person uh
that advice is
despite being the absolute truth
this absolute truth revealed prematurely
to
immature
consciousness is counterparty because
they would begin
by saying i am all that is i therefore
know everything and which is precluding
them from
the necessary admission that the
false i that they believe they are
knows anything
yes and i would add to that that it's
also a process that
happens in different cycles
ever expanding cycles of
well let's start with this this humbling
recognition that i know nothing then
from that there is um there's
this humility this opening to a greater
intelligence
that is allowed to flow through this
vessel
and then from this there is this
expression and then there is this
excitement and this joy and this this
free flow
and then that that will also get tainted
by the remnants of the false identity
that are still
um clinging to
this expression to the results
and that will distort this flow
and then it will come again to a point
of frustration of realizing that
actually i'm not fully it
i'm not fully me and so there comes
again a point of
i don't know
and owned
the unmastered usage of the word i
is the culprit is the it's not the
corporate obviously
it is the catalyst
understanding the
life dance that you are
which you tend to believe is happening
around you as a separate being
rather than within you
but before you jump into that truth
it's very important to number one
accept that the i that you still think
you are now
knows nothing then the next stage
is to stop totally using the word
i in recognition that
you keep attributing the wrong
things and the wrong identity to that
eye
and then when and as and when
the reality of your being becomes
clear and real and anchored in your
being and it's in its expression
i can now speak through you
and that word can be used again
that single letter word can can be used
again
so profound love it
great answers you guys such a good
question too
oh any new question
yeah i would love to say that
for simplifying this as well like has
been
mentioned by many of the most
quote successful geniuses
in the physical
they frequently have stories of where
they defocus from the physical
focus in a more relaxing
and they go on walks into nature
and what happens is that exact
difficult problem that they were
trying to figure out just
lightning bolts the creative solution
or it comes to them in the dream or
comes to them in all of these
different more relaxed scenarios the
very
defocusing from the physical
enables the more
relaxed guidance from that higher
intelligence to streamline itself
through so because it must be understood
that the entire ego construction
is an exercise in focus
it is the the entire thing then fighting
is the
reduction of consciousness into a finite
finite small self
concept so
if you want to access the truth that is
there within you in the wider
being that you are you have to start
focusing on maintaining that ego
to relax it so that it it
widens and widens until it widens enough
to include the answer to
what you were seeking the problem
usually
that when you get that answer suddenly
you recontract
because that's all you were after after
an answer
and then you recontract into your ego
and you just carry
along that answer but just
keep relaxed and that answer will still
be there
and many others as you widen your
consciousness
but please go ahead
yeah that's the entire leela
is the very
explorative process of taking
this identity of
nothingness to everythingness
and undergoing this spectrum of
identities where you have this very
small
contracted identity which doesn't get
much intuition
small finite contracted
egoic identity obsessed with its
conditioning trying to find peace and
happiness in
maya seeking it in experiences and
substances and
relationships is inevitably
going to get less intuition it's going
to hit
get more suffering get hit with the
sledgehammer until it
like in the parable of the prodigal son
turns inward to investigate the very
nature of awareness itself
and the very nature of even its source
and in doing so
that ego construct relaxes it then
expands to include these answers that we
just talked about
and then intuition becomes much more
i see it here i see it there it becomes
like an augmentation and perception
that was always there but you were
blinded because
your perception was focused on trying to
find peace and happiness
in maya and you weren't seeing
the sign posts which you now
see more as you awaken
cool so
beautiful we have another question that
was lined up beforehand
and then we'll see if we have a good one
from the audience as well
so why don't you shoot
two three questions so that
we can cover more for the satisfaction
of the people who did post questions
let's address this question that came
the last couple of days into the flow
it's a really good question
and then if there is another audience
question um before we wrap we'll take
it so for those tuning in that want to
drop a question go ahead and drop it in
the live chat
and we'll address it uh but right now
there is not um a question besides this
one
to address so let's go ahead and address
this one so
this kind of plays on the first question
so
the question is can you address
what remains the same after awakening
versus what changes after awakening
as people say everything is the same
yet totally different and this follows
that very
fun zen aphorism before enlightenment
shop would carry water after
enlightenment shop would carry water
or in the more modern day it's before
awakening do laundry after awakening do
laundry
so this is a great question let's see
how
our three take it excited can i start
yes please i was actually wanting to
talk about it before this question came
out
and i was thinking like i wonder if the
synchronicity going to work beautifully
for me now and yes
i got it right um do you know what guys
this is this is the relaxing the ego for
me right to realize
like for me i see god as this playful
child right that just absolutely loves
playing that's why he plays live right
he just wants to play
and created all the games and created
all the costumes they can
you know dress itself up and play all
these different roles and play all
these different games of you know going
to work or having families or going
traveling
or you know having enemies and doing the
war you know like even going to war and
having a fight
and and it's just god just loves playing
in all this and
when i when you observe child it's just
so incredible because that's
that's just like god is like child life
so playful so
let's see we look at child and child
plays with his mate and starts playing
some kind of i don't know let's play
armies or something and they start
you know fighting and shooting and blah
blah blah and then they play
so well that they eventually forget
themselves
and they so fully engaged in the game
they so fully they they think i'm the
army guy
right i'm the army guy and i'm playing
with the army guy and they get lost in
that game completely
so they starting fighting and being
really serious about it when they
just have a full-on argument and
tantrums to follow up right
after that so i see this is exactly what
has been happening with the the play
as we see here in the world is like the
the god is playing
so intensely getting so engaged
eventually gets lost
in the game and forgets what it is who
it is that he
first place created the game so what
happens after awakening you realize
you back into this child place oh you
know
this is all just a game just a play
right
so you're still fully engaged with the
games and you're more you're more aware
more conscious so you're more conscious
of which gay you want to play and you
want to engage in which you don't so you
make different choices right for
yourself
or where you go and where you're going
to engage and you're also done
you're not you're in the world why you
know afterwards so you this attachment
this
addiction to the game to the emotional
traumas and dramas the game produces it
releases it
it loosens the grip on you
therefore you are able to play without
that attachment play without the drama
play without the you know the the
suffering uh you really realize it for
what it is and you realize you're
placing it
so then you are back in the costume
being back being ula
right and having a fun with it you're
literally having
fun with it and always
able to go back to the place of i am
all of this and i am prior of
any reality uh ward
you know mata so i think that's that's
for me that's that's the beauty of
being yeah doing the language still so
still taking part in playing however
joyfully you know just having fun with
it rather than
suffer with it and struggle with it
that's my intake
and understanding
thanks for that
[Music]
play with yourself like you guys like
you're just another me right
like you we are all well please don't
reveal too much of our intimacy
[Laughter]
come on
no more shyness i don't know right
nothing to hide anymore
well
but it's it's also part of the play to
to hide to disguise ourselves
and to to play to play the game of
forgetting and to play the game of
being really serious about that play and
um
to play the game of being me
and just like there was nothing to add
and nothing to hide there is still
something to subtract
apart from the ego and the sense of
wrongs and
the wrong concept of self um
many spiritual people
make a mistake trying to
prematurely read
or try and
prevent the development of the
development of an ego by their children
you're getting a lot of static in your
mic can you just yeah
yeah yeah yeah there's a bit of link so
what is to subtract some people devoted
to spiritual
research tend to
want to suppress the development of ego
in their children
and uh this is not necessarily
helpful in fact it's uh
it is counter-productive because
uh there is a lack of understanding of
the
usefulness of the development of a
pretty strong ego in
the first phase of life which is
which will create more friction with
reality which will create a
darker night of the soul which will
be the perfect scene
for a more bright
and contrasting revelation
at the right time
in world time
yeah we all should be entitled to play
right to forget and to remember and to
forget to remember because
if you don't forget then this moment of
remembering which is so profound
wouldn't be given it's like the contrast
the contrast that we experience
brings the beauty of the remembering
right that the darkness when you go for
darkness the soul suddenly fall into joy
i'm like you would never appreciate the
joy as much if you know
if you didn't have the dynamite of the
soul right so it's like
it is i mean yeah that's the whole point
exactly it's like trying to open a
flower
prematurely it will be damaged or
trying while the kid is playing
cowboy and indians or whatever you are
don't forget you are not a cowboy don't
forget you are not an indian
come on let them play first
let me be an indian yeah exactly and
then if they start crying that ah he
killed me
he's a he's a nasty cowboy and now he
i'm dead and
i don't want to be bad okay then you can
tell him
okay remember you are not an indian but
don't remind him he's not an indian or
cowboy while he's having fun
yeah yes guys listen i love you know i
had only one hour so i have to check out
because my boy is playing football now
and i even last quarter and i have to
pay this right
such a joy to have you with them thank
you
[Music]
that was so nice that she joined yay
oh that last part was getting really
good
it's like even after you
quote pierce the
veilless veil the gateless gate
and unite with your true nature
even sharing the awakening
ruins the game well it's part of the
game for
catalyzing because you were capitalized
by others
don't forget you are not forcing your
your channel on your youtube videos on
anybody
so it's their intuition guiding them to
watch the right video at the right time
um however when you are in your
embodied life felix v and atlas
never forget that while you can
be totally boundless and without
restraint
when talking in a channel
which is only accessible by free will
when interacting with people
in the flesh or directly
there's this necessity to instantly
check if the permission slip is there if
it's the right time the right maturity
and the only way for you to know is to
be asked or to receive a very
clear permission slip yeah that's
essentially
and these things get refined anyway like
we bump our heads against the walls and
then
we learn
to make mistakes
and indeed don't bang your head against
the wall
don't bend your head against the wall
don't
[Laughter]
yeah usually the banging of the head
against the wall
is when it's already
way past the fan is gone already
well you know it's like it's like when
you fall
the problem is not falling it's when you
hit the ground
now the best way is to remove the ground
if somebody falls
if you can do that you don't need a
permission slip
so for
what remains the same versus what
changes
it's almost as though you
like we talked about with frank yang on
the show
that you only know this
first level and we gave this example
also earlier with you only know the
level of
objects and so you don't actually know
truly from a place of subtle
awareness
of perception itself you're not you
haven't recognized
the true salience of being a seer
of knowing yourself as god of piercing
that bayless fail to that level
and so in a sense you're in this state
and you don't know you haven't pierced
that veil to get back with that one
layer
and so what happens is you pierce back
the layer pop back that layer
you become more aware that there's
another part to this game that you
weren't aware of
then you recognize that even that is
shared and eternal
and then you pop even to the very source
of awareness and of realities and so now
basically what happens is you can
navigate the very nothingness
to the very infinitude from the very
impersonal awareness perspective to the
very engaging with an object or
experience
and you can do it from a more
frictionless perspective where you're no
longer
being sorry for getting you
um and apologized
an apology presented to you for
interrupting you because
um with all due respect what you are
saying
only makes sense to already quite
advancely awakened
souls it cannot make any sense
to people who have not had already a
couple
of degrees of awakening
and many of the people who have a
misconception about awakening
will be confused and uh
and despaired by those descriptions
because they are too
far from the their experience okay
one very important realization is that
it's it's quite rare actually that the
awakening
happens in a single big bang for most
expressions
incarnated expressions of i
the awakening will be a series
of bands and pops like you
you call them each of them increasing
to a certain degree the density
of being and the vastness of
consciousness so to
yes yes very careful not to
sustain the misconception that
enlightenment or awakening
happens in one big bang it is very rare
when it does
it's almost in a series of successive
realizations that each of them
incrementally
increase the yes
so the reason why i was making that
description and
the reason why you made that great point
which is that it's very relevant to an
advanced
level of understanding of the navigable
roadmap
which is a great point then the next
place that i'm going with this point
and that was a great reflection along
the trajectory but the next place that
i'm going with this point is that
what happens is rather than living
because we're addressing the question
rather than living pre-awakening what
you're doing
is you're living in a place where you're
trying
to as a physical
finite creature you're
trying to be happy and peaceful
but you're trying to get that from
experiences substances relationships the
illusion the intoxication
and so what's happening is you're
seeking
something transient in order for you to
get a hit
of dopamine feel goodness
which then disappears and then you
wonder okay well what's next i need
something else to fill the void
of feel goodness and so in a very
most layman term the
very outward focused non-awakened state
is trying to re-commune
with the very nature of what's been
described as satcha ranando over
millions of years which is the nature
that your
awareness itself existence consciousness
bliss is peace it is happiness
and so when you become fully aware of
that you basically relax
into the peace and joy that was already
present
sri aurobindo and the mother mir alfasa
call it the
the rock that was covering the well of
honey
and that in that process you no longer
post post this first pop in awakening
in a sense you
it's a very profound shift it's a very
very
very important cool profound shift
because you no longer feel
it used to be for many people as they
describe their awakening
that they were constantly trying to find
or
extract peace and happiness and instead
now what happens is that they
bring peace and happiness so at least
there's that
clarification as something that is very
cool
in the process i'm going to say goodbye
i don't really need to go but i feel
like going right now if you don't mind
okay v thanks for joining us yeah that
was so nice we're basically wrapped as
well
so thank you yeah thanks for joining us
it's been a great pleasure awesome
oh all right yeah go ahead yeah i just
wanted to
to add another perspective to this um
because i feel that what v was
expressing about
[Music]
the importance of the the gradual
nature of awakening i think it's
important to
torso and bring bring another
picture to
to to explain this point more um
so yeah one thing that we could say is
that the
the true the true me is pure awareness
so it's this pure space
of being it's pure potential that then
um shapes itself
into many different forms everything
that appears
and so one one
particular categories of this shape
is the the sense of a me
so it's like a crystallized
shape a form a structure
that then uh
rigidifies itself it's like this pure
consciousness which is very fluid very
free
it can shapes itself in all kinds of
ways
then it becomes very rigid very
stable and very
sterical also in some ways and so then
the process of awakening is then um
realizing that this uh crystallized
sense
of me is not the true me and then this
allows some dissolution to take place
and this is very much a process that
takes sometimes place in most cases
and so then what happens along the way
is that the more dissolution happens
the more it um
it allows for more movements so
where the flow of energy used to get
stuck
because there was like this rigidity
then
with more dissolution more opening
more more space in
being open in in that structure then
there is
a greater flow and a greater like
a smoother experiencing of of everything
then like the consciousness still takes
many shapes but then there's less
edginess there's less contraction
there's less rigidity there's less
resistance to the flow of
things there's a more just like a
natural harmonious gracious flaw
and
and yeah it's it's step along the way of
the
deconstruction of this structure uh
really makes
uh a true difference
in its own unique particular uh
aspect of of the life
awakening slash dissolving a loss for
more frictionless harmonious
movement yeah there's a
navigability that is
only accessible to
awakening you can't navigate beyond your
ego
conditioning when you're stuck there you
can't navigate into the subtle
formless awareness you can't tap into
that layer that's
already there but that you can't tap
into
because you haven't penetrated it
because your earnestness isn't high
enough on truth on desiring to know
to be free to know your true eternal
infinite nothingness nature and so
and then once you do pop in there and
you pop back
you go through those bits of awakening
again you no longer
seek peace and happiness and maya you
now bring peace and happiness everywhere
and you can navigate anywhere along
that spectrum frictionlessly
harmoniously
it's yeah that's probably that's
probably the main thing is the
frictionless
harmonious navigability of
all states of being an experience
yeah nice yeah
but laundry stays the same yeah
and what you do is you do it with
awakened love
and care and compassion rather than i
have to do the dishes right now
you know
it's called tantra for a reason you
weave your awakened realizations into
everything that you do
or sahaja yogi there's many ways to say
the weaving of the profound realizations
yeah and i i really like what bentino
said in one of the
mentorship con um
well
he was he was talking about different
aspect but what
one thing he was saying is that um
like some people imagine that uh the
point of life
is the enjoyment of the chocolate of the
i thought you were gonna say that the
ship yeah yeah yeah
and uh and then and then he was saying
that
he he enjoys chocolate and
he sometimes enjoys sex and he was he
was saying that he
he pops champagne for
[Music]
basically any reason he can find but for
him
it's an act of devotion and of
of giving so that that
that would be also an important shift of
perspective
like before awakening it's more like i
need to do this in order to get
something
or to avoid something perfect well
after awakening it's more like i'm i'm
just giving
i'm yeah i'm offering every
every act is an offering uh testimony uh
perfect
it becomes a giving every
every act is giving to god to the
creation to the play
rather than trying to extract from it by
popping this
or having sex or whatever i'm going to
get happiness yeah that's such a
huge great way to put it okay i think
that addresses a good amount of
the points also you become
in a sense much more you got to remember
the most simple one is the pause
right when you awaken you create a
greater pause so you're not as
reactive to the sensations and stimuli
but you use the breath enough to go
and you become more of an observer or a
witness of what's happening
and by creating that pause and not being
reactive
what happens is the anger typically
dissolves
in the other person or in the situation
or whatever is happening and unfolding
and so you basically
carry this incredible ability that
was latent in you
the pause all right let's address one of
the audience
questions that was really good that i
wanted to
bring up cool so let's
bring it up now
all right kev kev's question
how do i wake people up i love from the
reality of which
they are still living
great [ __ ] question
so
so one thing to see is that you
you cannot really force it upon people
um
all you can really do is be the example
and invite them seduce them
wood them in like given
given the taste for it given
um
but yeah i feel it's it's important to
to look at
where we're coming from with this kind
of uh
of question because um
[Music]
it can often be that we we perceive some
lag somewhere
that we're trying to compensate for
so maybe we believe that um
there's a problem in the way other
people are experiencing their lives
and that we should solve it
or maybe we feel that um
we we cannot really share with other
um on the level that we would like to
to share and to meet and
or maybe we just feel like that they are
[ __ ] annoying with the [ __ ]
and we would like to to live in more
harmonious and peaceful circumstances
and so all of these are a great um
uh great ways to reveal
where we are still identified
with um on not-self
with our false identity
and these points
are actually
where we are where we still get stuck
and so
where we cannot really embody
the example that
they would need us to be in order to
to be more invited in
so it's like the very points of
contraction of trying to help others or
to change others
are very often the points that we need
to
unlock in ourselves in order to
become the space that they actually need
for their transformation perfect
so yeah it's about it's about
being being the change you want to see
in the world yeah
perfect
[Music]
so great value in in just the love
just just show love to the people you
love
and that that will
that will um
i have a beautiful impact um
[Music]
it's just it there's nothing like love
you know it's it's both
uh it's both very beautiful
for you to be experiencing it and
and again it's a gift it's what you it's
what you're giving to the circumstances
so
by offering that love you
[Music]
it's like water in your garden
and you cannot force the plant to grow
but you can
provide some water and some lights on
the environment
and
[Music]
more chances to blossom
yeah felix definitely brought up the
core
themes so
to address this question
properly it's really nice to know
exactly where the person
is coming from because i remember
i'm right now about to give
something
which thinking about myself a year ago
i don't know if i would have been able
to actually receive this and i'm curious
maybe if this person
can actually receive this whole idea of
purifying where you're coming from
as we shared a moment ago because the
idea of check
okay why do i want to enlighten my mom
or my friend or how why do i want to
extract
liberate people from their shameless
chains in the matrix
to higher states of consciousness and so
that reflective process is really
mission critical
but i don't know if it can actually land
in the heart right now given where
people are at
experiencing elevated states and trying
to go
martyrdom overzealous action
in i will liberate my family i will
liberate my friends i will awaken and
shatter these chainless chains and so
i would say that if i was giving advice
that was a step below purify where
you're coming from which is the absolute
highest
step i would say the step below that
might be something like
your very intention for
wanting to help deliver
awakening is a sign that
you are here to be in service to other
people
and that's beautiful it's gorgeous
and the process
of you doing that is totally
not going to happen overnight and so
slow down as has been said in this
episode several times by our incredible
guests learn how to receive
from the universal music
and in doing so what's going to happen
is
you will become rather than over
zealously trying to deliver awakening
you'll notice that as you
receive more and just abide in these
more awakened states that you're
experiencing
naturally what's going to happen is
you're going to get a message from
someone
and it's going to be like hey it's going
to be a friend of yours and it's going
to be hey i noticed that
you're experiencing a lot of peace and
happiness your posts your videos
your content it's been great you know
seeing you at that event last week you
looked really happy
do you mind me calling you for 30
minutes just to talk
so now what you see is rather than you
bringing the awakening to
people what's happening is people are
coming to
you so you'll notice the sensitivity the
very subtlety will change because you
recognize that at a deeper level so i
would say
as felix said be the change you wish to
see
so take a step back from that sort of
overzealous
deliverance of awakening towards the
inner work
and as you refine and abide that
naturally
you'll find more and more scenarios
where
you'll deliver anywhere from a small
little watering as felix mentioned in
the analogy of the seed
to a little bit of sunlight as you pass
by that type of a thing
yeah i i would also like to build on
what you said about like
just the beauty of the the desire to be
of service to others it's
uh it's
it's a very beautiful setup from the
the one existence to to experience the
[Music]
on many different very rich interactions
that can take place
between different beings and so
and so i would say also to to trust that
impulse and to
and to go with it and knowing that
uh following this trail of excitement
will um will purify it
on the way like you you will learn by
trying and
by giving your best and by um
by also realizing what we were saying uh
about the intuition that
that you don't know you don't know how
to wake people up
there is the desire but then you you're
coming to a point where
it feels like
you don't know and so that that opens
you up
for pose and to really uh
become more humble and to let go of more
of your biases and assumptions
which will open you up to
to more intelligence as we were saying
before and that will allow you to be
used in a more skillful way
and and then again and again in this
practice and devotion and dedication and
sincerity
these things just unfold and become more
and more beautiful
excellent let's
wrap
this was yours from the beginning
awakening is reality becoming aware of
itself
and then this one was
i am a little person to i am the whole
of existence
this is when we were talking about
awakening to the very
absolute to the nothingness realize you
are even
prior to this creation you are the very
unmanifested you are the source of
infinite possibilities
this was our lovely osho by v
who am i or all also known as what
is i by ramana maharshi
is the only revolutionary act in the
universe
self-inquiry atom of vichara
this was a good one by v the root of all
misunderstanding
is the use of the unmastered eye that's
such a good one
and this was also you awakening
dissolving allows for more frictionless
harmonious movement
swift navigation jedi-like
chameleon joseph and the code of many
colors
be the change you wish to see in the
world really
really good stuff kev came back
in awesome guys thanks okay thank you so
much
we love you we're super grateful for you
thank you
thanks everybody for tuning in
yeah great and thanks for the little uh
recapitulation of our journey together
today
yeah really lovely
yeah it's my honor and pleasure this is
what i've
you know become skilled at and so it's
a lot of fun to be able to put it to
service
with awakening enlightenment and ama as
like this theme and to have such other
awakened representatives
as the guests in this
panel to be able to hit these really
good tennis balls
to answering these questions is just
like yes
this is exactly what we the divine
unfolding had in store
and i'm just so blessed and grateful
yeah
so good so good
thank you thanks everyone for tuning in
we're super grateful
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below
on the ama let us know
what you're thinking about the answers
that came through and also if you would
like to
you can go ahead and drop new
questions into the comments as well just
write new question and then put your
question and then what we'll do is we'll
crowdsource those questions into the
next
ama and
like the video for brought you value
helps the algorithm subscribe to the
channel if you haven't yet
and share the awakening ama with others
that you think
it would bring value to so
that's all and you can also find the no
limit society
link in the bio below as well if it
resonates
with your highest excitement it's an
incredible
navy seals of spirituality so
that is all infinite love and adoration
thank you so much everyone all right
felix you and i will stay in the
you and i will stay in the room i'll uh
i'll end the broadcast here
bye bye everyone
thanks thank you
thank you thank you thank you
hmm